evidentemente en este momento es lo que
eeuu se identifica como amenazas
prioritarias no está en el terrorismo
yihadista que ha pasado en segundo plano
después de 20 años si tengo que estar
centrado en la amenaza que implica china
para sus intereses y en segundo lugar
rusia y por lo tanto esto implica que
tiene que salir de un teatro de
operaciones que le complejiza la
posibilidad de frenar a china en lo que
es el espacio y no pacífico y de frenar
con sus aliados de la otan a rusia en la
tensión y el conflicto que se pueda
producir en el caso de ucrania en este
momento ahora anthony blinken dice que
se cumplieron los objetivos pero al
mismo tiempo bait en reconoce que hoy
por hoy las amenazas han cambiado cuáles
son estas nuevas amenazas
bueno justamente ahora las amenazas no
son las antiguas amenazas de dos actores
no estatales con este caso los
yihadistas en sus distintas formas que
amenazaron desde el 11 de septiembre del
2001 a eeuu sino que ahora las amenazas
vuelven a ser unos estados que están en
competencia y desarrolló una rivalidad
estratégica con eeuu en el sistema
internacional en un momento que el
sistema internacional está pasando por
un proceso de transición que
probablemente haga emerger un nuevo
orden mundial un nuevo sistema en donde
estos actores van a tener un papel de
peso no sabemos si este sistema va a ser
un sistema predominantemente bipolar en
el marco de la confrontación en la
rivalidad entre eeuu y china o si va a
ser multipolar con la participación de
otros actores o sea que por ejemplo
piensa si desde la perspectiva rusa
putin que se iba a ser un elemento
también en esta en esta dinámica de
carácter más policéntrico en el sistema
internacional ahora andrés ya para
finalizar qué consecuencias tendrá esto
a nivel local está listo afganistán para
tomar las riendas de su futuro
pero este es el gran interrogante lo que
pasa que ya en este momento hay toda la
serie de otros actores vecinos que están
involucrándose en la situación de
afganistán en primer lugar
eeuu se ha hecho un llamado a pakistán
para que apoye al gobierno en kabul para
resolver y llevar a buen término algún
proceso de paz con los talibanes en
segundo lugar
turquía está convocando en este momento
a fin de mes a una conferencia para
justamente llegar a algún tipo de
acuerdo de paz entre los contendientes
en afganistán
andrés gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted una feliz resto de noche